les résultats du confinement commence à
se faire sentir en belgique extrêmement
touché par la crise sanitaire le pays a
entamé fin octobre un confinement plus
sévère de 6 semaines
celui ci a entraîné la fermeture de tous
les commerces non essentiels les
entreprises doivent quant à elles
fonctionnaient en télétravail dans la
mesure du possible
mais ces mesures contraignantes portent
enfin leurs fruits
le ralentissement c'est évident et on le
constate on constate partout dans le
pays et chez nous bien entendu aussi je
suis quand même assez convaincu que le
confinement à a joué son rôle puisque
c'est clairement dans l'est dans les dix
quinze jours qui ont suivi la fermeture
de toute une série d'activités qui a
permis à de voir apparaître cette
diminution de décontamination et defacto
des hospitalisations
le ralentissement de l'épidémie peut
déjà observer par des chiffres
encourageants
à la fin du mois d'octobre on comptait
pas moins de quinze mille nouveaux cas
journalier contre moins de 4000
aujourd'hui le taux de positivité des
tests dépasser alors les 30% alors qu'il
se trouve à un niveau de 17 5%
actuellement le nombre de décès
quotidiens commence lui aussi à baisser
pourtant malgré les signes positifs ce
confinement affecte particulièrement les
belges sur le plan économique certains
allant même jusqu'à critiquer les
décisions du gouvernement
donc ça devient assez compliqué en plus
ma maman est là une petite pension et
donc de ma poche je mets comme un mille
euros pour qu'elle soit bien dans la
maison de repos et de blues je suis je
travaille dans un bar et je suis prof de
sport donc forcément les salles sont
fermées les barthes renfermé donc plus
de revenus je le vis mal parce que pour
moi c'est pas nécessaire
leur confinement n'est vraiment pas
nécessaire c'est une incompétence totale
de ceux qui nous dirigent et six avaient
fait leur boulot correctement
on n'aurait pas eu besoin la moselle
confinement une détresse qui s'illustre
par le suicide en début de semaine
d'alison jadin cette jeune femme de 24
ans avait dû fermer son barber shop
inauguré l'été dernier
lui causant de nombreux problèmes
financiers allison est aujourd'hui l'un
des symboles d'un pays qui peine à
maîtriser une crise sanitaire aux
impacts désastreux sur tous les plans